why do you think so many leaders  today are afraid to publicly discuss  important issues  that both themselves their families are  being impacted and the people at their  workplace well because there are  consequences for it there's no question  about that  but  remember  as our national anthem says in the end  of the first answer  the home of the brain  the land of the land of the free  you can't be the land of the free if  you're not the home of the prey  so unless you're actually willing to  stand up for what you believe in  your freedom is going to be gradually  eroded and that's been the history of  societies throughout the history of the  world  the united states  has been different up until now  and i say this is probably the most  extreme challenge  to who we are that we have ever had